-What a great crowd.
Guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Let's play.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Oh, I love you.
Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yep. You can vote
for all of them.
You can vote
for none of them.
Whatever you want to do,
we're gonna have fun.
We're gonna
see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers, too?
-Got it.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
on the show so that you can all
like it and "wetweet" it.
[ Cheering ]
It's a shared --
a shared experience.
All right.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheering ]
The first tweet is...
[ Scant laughter ]
-Wow.
-There's absolute silence.
-Yeah, absolute silence.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I'm gonna -- no.
I'm not even
gonna vote for that.
[ Laughter ]
-I voted no twice.
-This might be --
[ Laughter ]
-You voted no twice?
-Yeah.
-This might be a full-on no
on this one.
Let's just see the results
Wow.
Yeah, that's bad.
[ Laughter ]
All right, so it's not that.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-That was a tester.
-That was a test, yeah.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Eh.
-Well, compared to the last one.
-Yeah, compared to the last one,
that's pretty good.
-I'm gonna say 68. 68.
-I'd say it's probably half,
yeah.
Cast your votes. Let's see
the results right here.
What do we think?
Yeah, half, exactly.
Whoa!
-Wow.
-That's phenomenal.
That's right down the middle.
-Barely won.
-Yeah, I like that.
All right, this next one says --
here you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-It's a carrot top.
-Yeah.
-When you think about it.
You really think about it.
Carrot top...
-Carrot top gonna have green...
-I think -- I think it's gonna
be more than 60%.
-I think so. I think so.
-Yeah.
This will be
the best one so far.
I don't know. Let me see.
Take a look.
-145.
-Whoa! There you go!
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-That's --
-That's respectable.
-I think it was based
on the other ones.
-Sure.
[ Laughter ]
-I think
they're being very nice, yeah.
This next one says...
[ Light laughter ]
-Whoo!
♪♪
-Yeah.
-Well, if they're in that jar,
they get everywhere.
So, yeah, I kind of understand.
-Eh.
-It's just more of an invention,
maybe.
-Yeah, maybe more of a --
just a comment.
-Yeah. Good.
-Yeah.
-All right, let's see
the results on this one.
Yeah. All right. I agree.
♪♪
All right. It's probably
gonna be Carrot Top.
Unless, we have one more.
-One more.
-One more!
[ Cheering ]
-Five's a charm.
-I have a feeling
this one's gonna win.
I feel it.
All right, here we go.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
I already feel it.
I feel a landslide coming.
I feel a landslide coming here.
This is a good wave.
I'm gonna ride this wave out.
Cast your votes.
Let's see the results
right here!
Booooom, baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, it looks like the winner
is right there. Come on.
[ Dinging ]
Oh, yeah!
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet and enjoy.